Planned Parenthood made the difficult
and personal decision yesterday to
terminate their president after just 10
months or a little over three trimesters
in the position it is unclear whether
Planned Parenthood used chemicals or
forceps to evacuate president lianna Wu
from her office bizarrely Wu took to
Twitter to complain about the ouster as
though she were a human being but it's
Planned Parenthood's corporate body and
it's Planned Parenthood's choice besides
it's not like they killed her or
anything we will examine what the firing
means for the modern left then breaking
news from the floor of the House of
Representatives Democrats who have spent
the last three years calling President
Trump a racist voted you'll never guess
it to call President Trump a racist
Wow they are doing the people's work
finally our pal bill Whittle stops by to
talk about his new hit podcast Apollo 11
what we saw on the 50th anniversary of
the moon landing all that and more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
there was some real craziness on the
floor of the House of Representatives
yesterday and it has a lot to do with
those tweets that President Trump sent
out a couple days ago and it tells us a
lot about the reaction of some
conservatives to those tweets of the
hole left to those tweets and whether
the tweets in overall were productive or
unproductive for the politics of 2020
we'll get into it first I want to get to
Planned Parenthood because this is a
pretty crazy story and the media aren't
really covering it very much Planned
Parenthood just fired their president
lianna woo after less than one year
guess why there are two reasons being
reported from multiple sources within
Planned Parenthood the reason that they
fired their president is because the
President believes lianna Wu believed
that abortion was more popular when it
was framed as a health care issue rather
than a political issue
seems true enough to me I'm sure it is
more popular when you don't frame it as
some crazy leftist political agenda but
you just try to call it health care you
know the second reason why they fired
her thus according to two sources
speaking to BuzzFeed news because she
wouldn't say that men can have abortions
the president of Planned Parenthood
refused to say that dudes don't have
uteruses don't have a birth canal she
refused to say that dudes can have
abortions so they fired her for that
can't make this stuff up she said two
true things and they fired her for that
this tells us a lot tells us a lot about
where the left is where Democrats are in
in regard to their own ideology where
they are in regard to believing their
own press releases where they are in
regard to following their own crazy
premises to their highly illogical
conclusions you know I spoke yesterday
about this article in The Wall Street
Journal over the weekend about men
beating women at women's sports
so Maddie Kearns wrote this piece in the
journal about how these high school
girl track stars are being beaten out
they're losing scholarships that can't
win any races because men keep competing
in them and men are physically stronger
than women and so they keep winning now
that this has significant consequences
at the high school level obviously means
they could lose out on scholarships
that's real money that really affects
your college career that really affects
your life socially though it means that
men now get to define what womanhood is
and if women object to this then the
women are smeared is some sort of bigot
as a trans folk you know when Maddie
wrote that piece in the Wall Street
Journal
there was this weirdo this creepy Gaea a
male New York Times freelance op IDI
and a graduate of Harvard Medical School
tells you a lot about Harvard Medical
School his name is Jack turbine he
smeared her as a bigot he said The Wall
Street Journal shouldn't have published
her because she referred to men as men
and women as women he said The Wall
Street Journal shouldn't have published
her because she defended women's sports
so I mentioned this on the show
yesterday now he's smearing me he's
saying that I hate transgender people of
course he provides no evidence for this
he couldn't find any evidence for that
but he's smearing me as being hateful
toward transgender people because I
think that women's sports should exist
and I think that women who defend
women's sports shouldn't be smeared by
weirdos who write for the New York Times
that's a I guess that's what qualifies
hatred toward transgender people now
obviously nothing could be further from
the truth and I think it's time for
conservatives to start articulating this
and not just conservatives by the way
moderates left-wingers even Democrats
anybody who thinks that men are not
women and women are not men and that
women ought to be allowed to exist and
women ought to be allowed to have their
own changing rooms and they ought to be
allowed to have their own sports if
anything it is gender ideology activists
like Jack turban who demonstrate hatred
toward gender confused people why is
that it's because they won't tell them
the truth
they think the whole gender ideology
crowd think that the very very small
percentage of people who suffer from
this condition of gender confusion 0.2%
something like that they think that
they're hopeless they think there is no
chance these people are so crazy there's
no way that you could ever tell them the
truth they can't handle the truth
you just have to indulge their delusions
like you would a small child
how come descending is that how pompous
is that how self ad EULA Tory is it to
say I know the truth look we all know
the truth but these little feeble-minded
people there's no way we could possibly
tell them that they're not really the
opposite sex the sex that they want to
be or that they might have deluded
themselves into thinking that they are
they would rather be people like Jack
turban the gender ideology people they
would rather feed these people delusions
even delusions that harm those
individuals even delusions that harm
society even delusions that harm girl
track stars female athletes they would
rather feed them those delusions than
give them the truth that sex is real
we're born with a sex it is what it is
this is such an affront to human dignity
to treat some people as though they're
fundamentally incapable of understanding
reality it's so it's so outrageous and
on this topic I mean from the women's
sports all the way to firing a Planned
Parenthood president because she says
men can't have abortions I have to say
as someone with a dog in this fight as a
conservative I encourage them to keep it
up oh please political activists please
keep it up keep on smearing women for
trying to get college scholarships for
sports
keep on smearing women keep on trying to
convince people that men are women and
up is down and left is right keep on
firing activists for saying that men
can't get abortions keep on smearing
women for we're trying to compete in
their own sports people have eyes and
you can't tell people forever that they
can't believe their own lyin eyes we are
watching the left collapse
under the weight of their own illogic in
real time this is a hopeful moment for
those of us in the reality-based
community we will explain why we'll
explain what it means in one second but
first rake on earbuds are a wonderful
new product they help you hear reality
we all see reality ray con will help you
hear it at about half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market they sound fantastic so ray cons
'if if t wireless earbuds have
completely changed the game they're
extremely comfortable much more
comfortable than any other year but on
the market and they're extremely easy to
take anywhere so unlike some other
wireless options I'm not going to name
them but I think we all know what we're
talking about here ray con earbuds are
stylish and discreet they're not like
dangling out of your ears with giant
stems or wires and it's not just that
they look great they sound great too ray
con offers their wireless earbuds for
everyone in a range of colors it's not
just some company telling you it has to
look like this it has to feel like this
even if it doesn't fit too bad deal with
it we say so it's an unbeatable price as
well right now go to buy rakin comm
slash Knowles canna wles
get 15% off your order you're not gonna
get that anywhere else by rakin comm /
Knowles for 15% off rake on wireless
earbuds if you have been eyeing a pair
now is the time to get an amazing deal
one more time by Ray Khan RA Y Co n comm
/ Knowles canna wles
I've said this for months now I think
that this moment this crazy gender stuff
is the moment that is causing the left
to collapse under the weight of its own
illogic how unified was Planned
Parenthood not two years ago Planned
Parenthood was totally resurgent I mean
they were they're getting all this
taxpayer money they've got all these
marches in the streets they've got all
the women wearing the pink hats they
were on the move and now they're firing
their own president because the
president said that men can can't get
abortions so we're told
the the pro-life movement is a war on
women but women can also be men and
abortion is a woman's healthcare right
but it's now it's a reproductive health
care right even if it's not about
reproduction even if it affects men very
very confusing topic this is how we're
gonna win just keep pushing them through
the looking-glass you know there there
has been this this movement on the right
this has been for a few years now those
who say we've got to abandon the
old-school
of trying to fight them point by point
and just yell and scream and get
exasperated just let the left destroy
itself just let the left go crazy on its
own it's I would call it acceleration
ISM they're saying forget about fighting
on the question of I don't know if we
got to fighting on the scientific merits
of abortion wait until you're fighting
on this on the scientific merits of what
sex is wait until you've got them trying
to force grown men into the girls locker
room at that point nobody is going to
support these people let them go through
the looking-glass it's got to get
crazier before it gets saner and so I
think some people now are looking at
this in there they're saying oh no this
is the great triumph of leftism because
they're putting grown men in the women's
room I think it's just the opposite I
think there is a huge awakening going on
I mean actually there is a study out
from pew that shows that the youngest
generation you know the gens e-types are
beginning to question the LGBTQ
transgender ideology of the left they're
actually much more skeptical of it than
Millennials or even Gen X that's pretty
interesting
how did that change happen it's because
the left has overplayed its hand and
it's because also you you sort of laugh
at it I mean it is just ridiculous on
its face Planned Parenthood fires its
president because she says that men
can't have abortions fifty years ago
Democrats promised to put a man on the
moon today their biggest battle that
they're fighting is putting a man in the
ladies room that is ridiculous
this is one small step for man one giant
leap in girls high school lacrosse it's
ridiculous
let's just turn for a moment we'll get
back to the craziness of the left cos
it's not just falling apart in planned
parenthood it's not just falling apart
on the pages of the New York Times or in
girls high school track or any of that
it is falling apart in the halls of
Congress before that though let's take a
break from this present nonsense let's
get to the great historical feats and
let's talk about the moon landing on the
fiftieth anniversary this month marks
that anniversary and there's an exciting
new podcast out by esoteric radio
theater called Apollo 11 what we saw yet
immediately skyrocketed to number three
on the iTunes Apple podcasts app and
it's still in the top five even days
later episode 3 in the beginning drops
today and just coincidentally it's being
hosted by our old pal Bill Whittle
author pilot and space enthusiasts who
takes you on the journey of what it took
to get to the moon and what happened
when we got there and also very
excitingly how things almost went
horribly horribly wrong head over to
Apple podcasts or wherever you listen to
podcasts and subscribe today to Apollo
11 what we saw when we bring on Bill
Whittle welcome to Apollo 11 mission
control what's left of it anyway
the space race 12 years of open warfare
between two superpowers we used our best
missiles our best pilots ion it an
engineer we employed aircraft carriers
radar stations all the military hardware
we had to defeat our ideological nemesis
when each team had over 20,000 nuclear
warheads apiece
the space race was the defining act of
the second half of the 20th century 50
years ago men from Planet Earth first
set foot upon the moon you owe it to
yourself and a history to experience the
Space Age from the inside and see how it
took hundreds of small steps to get to
that one giant leap I'm Bill Whittle and
this is what we saw I will tell you the
whole podcast is as impressive as that
trailer how cool does that sound we're
joined by the host Bill Whittle good to
see you pal how you doing bill how are
you you're a hit this show goes up for
five hours or something and it's and it
goes straight to the top three on the
all of the iTunes charts when I was 10
years old I basically designed the moon
landing and and set up the Apollo
program to be in place so that when I
became 60 my podcast would would reach
stratospheric Heights thank you thank
you for the kind words it's I enjoyed
writing it the production work done here
is out of the park and obviously the
reason people are so interested in this
is because of the anniversary because of
the story and you know you're setting
this up when you were 5 years old is
only one of the conspiracies that I want
to get to about the moon landing but
first I actually just did a column on
this yesterday because of your podcast
I'd seen a few rumblings about this
there is an episode from the moon
landing that NASA basically blacked out
they didn't want people to know about
they told all Buzz Aldrin to shut up
about it you've got the the Eagle lunar
module lands finally on the moon itself
and it's not like they just hop out it's
not like they park their Chevy and
they're going into the movie theater
there there is a there are a number of
hours in between the landing and when
they go out and walk around the moon
what happens during those hours well
they were gonna they were gonna make the
moonwalk about 12 hours after the
landing but for some reason landing on
the
and having all these failures and all
this other stuff down having the entire
planet looking at them and everybody is
entire attention focus on him turns out
the guys weren't that sleepy after all
you know so they moved it up six hours
but during that six hours Mike once they
once they had the the LEM secured shut
down by the way you just mentioned they
didn't have to get out of there in a
hurry
when Armstrong got onto the surface of
the Moon the first thing he did was pick
up something called the contingency
sample he pulled out a scoop picked up
some stuff put it in a patch in case
buzzes you know we got to go we got to
go right now so we had we had something
with us but but during that time there
was still several hours before they
started to get into their suits for for
the the moonwalk which was six hours
after landing and during that time Buzz
Aldrin did something that he had asked
permission to do and it's not like NASA
covered it up it's not like they denied
any existence of it but it was needless
to say not publicized armes Aldrin had
taken with him gotten permission to take
with him these two pouches when he got
to the moon he removed this little
silver flask he opened one of the
pouches and he poured a liquid into the
flask and he said in the one-sixth
gravity it was amazing how how graceful
all the little bits of it you know
curling around the thing room then he
opened the other package and poured the
contents of that into his other hand he
radioed Mission Control and he's talking
to the mission controllers now but this
is not going out to the public it's just
for basically for NASA he said I think
at this point I would like to ask
everybody to take a moment to give
thanks and whatever they find
appropriate for this amazing achievement
and then since he was an elder at the
Presbyterian Church back in Houston he
took a consecrated wafer he had a sip of
wine from the chalice and he had a
communion on the moon the first fluid
ever poured on another planet was wine
this is an astounding moment I mean
especially when you look at it in the
context of the Cold War in the space
race you have the first foods and
liquids poured prepared on the moon are
the consecrated body and blood of Christ
it is this and here I believe he read
from the Gospel of John to I I am divine
what he read I'm sure he read an
appropriate short piece of scripture
basically to himself Armstrong
didn't participate I don't know if
Armstrong was worried about the fallout
or not but it's pretty clear that he
wasn't that this was buzzes show right
but buzz you know you've just not just
this one time risked your life you've
been risking the only life you've got
for 10 or 15 years now and and 40 years
after landing so 10 years ago when Buzz
wrote his memoirs he actually almost
started to you could tell that 40 years
of political correctness was starting to
work on him Alyssa's look you know I
don't know maybe I regret it now but at
the time I just felt like you know what
how else can you give thanks for this
incredible thing that we've pulled off
this was my personal way of course and
you know you've got the god-fearing
Americans basically you've got this what
remains of Western Christendom versus
godless atheism you know we think of the
Cold War in economic terms free markets
versus collectivism that was obviously a
huge part of it the other side of it was
the atheism of communism you know when
pope john paul ii went to poland had an
open-air mass you the people chanted we
want god this is so much an animating
facet and we beat the the soviets we get
on the moon first and you had it all
during gives his his broadcast he says
everyone give thanks in a private way
and then deferring to nasa deferring to
political correctness he turns off the
radio he reads the scripture to himself
and he takes the communion privately
which is an astounding historical moment
why was NASA so worried about Buzz
Aldrin taking communion on the moon you
know Mike I grew up with the space
program I was going to be an astronaut I
asked me to do the show because I know
the space program very well and I had
heard about the communion thing when I
when I did the research
after done having done political
commentary for ten years now it hit me
like a thunderbolt that we landed on the
moon in at 4:17 Eastern Time on the 20th
of July 1969 that was the end of the
space race that was the United States
defeating communism six hours later we
walk on the moon and in the time between
having our cake and eating it too in
that six hour window political
correctness was born and and the and the
space age as we understood it ended in
that six hour window because what had
happened was
on a previous mission to year a little
over a year earlier a year and a half
earlier Apollo 8 which was kind of an
ad-lib mission we had a bunch of
astronauts and capsules we didn't have
the lunar module so what are we gonna do
well let's just go to the moon we got
nothing else to do in orbit around the
moon so as as that crew Lovell Borman
and Anders are coming around for their
final orbit it's Christmas Day back on
earth and they see the earth rising
above the moon no one's ever seen this
before and and they decided that they
were going to send a Christmas message
to earth so they read a little bit from
the book of Genesis and as the earth is
rising on Christmas Day back home you
hear the crew of Apollo 8 with their
message and say in the beginning God
created the heaven and the earth and
they read a little bit of Genesis and
then they ended it Frank Borman ended it
with a line I just think it's beautiful
line improv lines he says so from the
crew of Apollo 8 we'd like to wish you
good night good luck Merry Christmas and
God bless all of you all of you on the
good earth and they start home well
Madalyn Murray O'Hair who was a
professional atheist a real atheist
rights person and by the way I just need
to interrupt this and say it bears
mentioning needless to say that large
numbers of NASA engineers were atheists
and some of them were Jews and some of
them were anything else but that's not
the point here
Madalyn Murray O'Hair was so outraged
that somebody might say something like
like that from the moon that she sued
NASA on behalf of her a theist
organization and that's this would this
is Christmas 1968 so this is not very
Liz about six seven months before the
that's Apollo 11s it was a year and half
earlier it's it's right it's it's it's
about Christmas 68 we landed July 6
tonight so she sues NASA and she loses
but NASA decides that they don't need
the bad publicity and here is the
beginning of pretty political
correctness in that six hours between
defeating communism we and and walking
on the moon we took Anita communism we
bowed to it because what NASA basically
said was hey buzz I know you've risked
your entire life and and have
accomplished the most amazing thing ever
in the history of the world and we
understand that these are your personal
religious convictions we're not saying
you're speaking for
the entire program please please because
that loud people will keep us yeah
because this one woman who who is the
head of the American Atheists widely
called the most hated woman in America
the total she worked hard for shows she
worked hard yes she was by all accounts
a completely loathsome person and an
avowed communist and and the point I'm
making is not so much whether it's not
to say that the the American space
program was a religious based program
they said it was it what but what it
does what it does say is as far as I'm
aware as an amateur historian that was
the first time I can remember when
Americans were told don't say what you
really think
hide your core beliefs do not do
anything that might upset the lunatics
because they write a lot of letters and
they make are like a because and they
might as they did now you said that this
was the greatest achievement in all of
human history but I have spent a lot of
time on the internet bill I've read a
lot of blogs okay I've seen a lot of
YouTube videos so I know for a fact that
we didn't land on the moon yeah a lot of
people know that that's right and so I
want you how can you explain to me how
we it landed on the moon when for
instance human beings couldn't possibly
survive the Van Allen radiation belts
checkmate
see you next time bill yeah there there
has been an enormous Lies spread about
the moon landing there have been there
been lies about the subject since it
happened but NASA's not the one doing
the line the people doing the lying are
the people who are selling this product
this this product that it's a hoax and
the Van Allen radiation belts are one of
just many examples of of them lying in
order to make money
the hoax ists the conspiracy guys so
they say here's the earth here's the
vanillin radiation belts we can't get to
the moon without flying through them
because the radiation levels going to be
able what they don't tell you is here's
the earth here's the Van Allen radiation
belts there's the moon but the moon's
orbit is inclined at an angle which
means that during a very brief period
when it crosses the axis then you have
to go through the belts and then you can
either fly under them or wait to that
one day window when you if you really
determine
to kill your crew you can fly right
through him then or as the moon climbs
above that the plane of the belts you
fly over them now the outer belts are a
little wider so they Nick the edge of
the outer belts and when somebody says
it's absolutely impossible my response
is okay what level of radiation is out
there that's impossible
oh they fry them like it was in a
microwave but microwaves don't emit
radiation microwaves cooking with
electromagnetic energy they don't admit
neutrons there so so you're saying they
it's like they were put in a machine
that doesn't make any radiation how much
radiation they take they won't tell you
they'll just say it's impossible well as
it turns out we know what the radiation
levels are we knew in advance and it
turns out that they took about one point
five red a REM just to give you an idea
it's just that it's a name
it's a radiation dose but to give you an
idea today the government has rules for
how much radiation a worker can take in
a given year
if you're working a nuclear plant or
medical imaging or airline crews because
it's been a lot of time we fly too much
right so the limit per year according to
government regulations the maximum that
you can take and still be safest is 5
rim and they took 1.5 rim so they took
about a third more than they would have
taken if they'd stayed out in okay all
right so you got me on the Van Allen
radiation okay fair enough uh how come
bill how how could we have gotten to the
moon when we know for a fact we didn't
have the technology to go to the moon
and by the way we can't even go to the
moon today check mate check er mate
maybe when somebody says we don't have
the technology we didn't have the
technology to go to the moon I would
respond what gives you that idea
what makes you make that assertion we
had built 1575 rockets and we launched
13 of them the other two went to museums
so there were 13 rockets that developed
seven million pounds of thrust that took
off from Kennedy Space Center not
recorded after the fact like the Soviets
live in a person I saw two of them go
there were tens of millions of people at
the Cape watching that Saturn 5 go into
the air so if what you're telling me is
we have the technology to build a three
hundred and sixty-five foot rocket that
can with six million pounds off of the
pad and we have the technology to do
this but we don't have the technology to
use the extra one percent of energy
needed to get us to the moon I don't buy
it because because if you had told me
that that there was no such thing as a
Saturn five in other words if the
hardest part of the equation right was
missing you might have a case but what
they will say is they'll say okay well
the Saturn fives really launched but we
didn't go to the moon we just stayed in
lunar orbit why but more importantly
well why was this giant moon landing
conspiracy constructed to beat the
Soviets ah there it is let's see if just
so you've answered it but here's my
question if it turns out that the Apollo
missions actually left because everybody
saw them right and they went into Earth
orbit yeah but they didn't go to the
moon and since the Soviets have radars
that can determine where everything is
in space just like we do you would think
that if we were trying to lie to the
Soviets in the world by pretending to go
to the moon yeah do you think that the
Soviets might have had something to say
about this like hey sorry to interrupt
the fun but we can show radar returns of
the thing in orbit which means Mike that
the Soviets were in on the conspiracy
they were to defeat the Soviet that's
well this okay all right maybe you've
presented a slight problem for this
theory but I've got one this puts to
rest all of your silly fantasies that we
went to the moon that footage that we
all saw of Apollo 11 we can almost
certainly tell was filmed in a
soundstage just right here in Los
Angeles okay because you know the flag
was waving or something and they and I
haven't read too much about it but
anyway what I know is we filmed it in a
soundstage prove me wrong oh there's a
couple things I'll say about that first
of all it's interesting that the flag
waving that they claimed as evidence of
air they say a gust of wind came through
the studio so something you worry about
here that's only when Ben rips my wall
out of the wind store it's interesting
though that that waving only occurs for
just a few moments after they let go of
the flagpole if you've ever had a golf
flagpole in your hand you know if you
let that thing go it'll
Bradon wobble and without air resistance
to slow the flag down it maintains that
momentum a little bit longer which is
actually evidence that it was on the
moon nah but it wasn't so here's the
thing Mike anybody can google this goose
goose Buster's ghost Mythbusters did a
great job with this you know what a you
know what a real way
oil tanker looks like right these big
heavy steel things that carry oil well
if you google oil tanker vacuum anywhere
on YouTube a couple people have done
experiments where they take most of the
air out of an oil tanker they set up
with vacuum over here they open a valve
and they pull the air that's inside the
tanker out and these massive huge steel
things just go punch like that it'll
blow your mind
blow your mind under the pressure of
pressure the atmosphere yeah so the most
the biggest vacuum chamber in the world
is called the space power facility you
can google that too the walls are
something like 15 feet that gets
enclosed inside of that is a steel
chamber the walls are like two feet
thick and it is not big enough to get
the limb into and that is the largest
area that we can make into a vacuum on
the surface of the earth because of the
incredible air pressure so the question
is if you built it on a soundstage and
since the action of the dust is showing
it it's a dust in a vacuum he drops a
feather at a hammer and they fall at the
same time right all of 15 then what
you're saying is is that the sound stage
had to be in a vacuum and it's harder to
build a building the size of a sound
stage that is good man the best way to
fake the moon landing mic is to do it on
the moon that's it and I'll just say one
more thing if all of this is true and it
is a giant enormous lie in order to
convince the world that we beat the
Soviets and all of it is in danger of
being exposed and if it turns out that
if if Neil Armstrong decides to squawk
NASA is just gonna shoot him in the head
then why would we go a second time well
this is the why would we keep going and
why would and why would it be that when
we go after two more times why would we
put a gulf cart on on the moon which is
transmitting a live video the entire
time Paolo 17 went 12 miles that's a big
soundstage now if there hadn't been a
moon rover would you have missed it hey
that can't be right there's no
Rover on that mission no so why would
you go six times every time going
further and further and further in this
in this soundstage it now has to be the
size of Montana you know what I think it
is I think where all these hoaxes come
from is because modern people in living
in 2019 who are so smart and so fabulous
they can't believe that 50 years ago in
the old-timey days when everything was
in black and white and they didn't even
have snapchat that those guys could do
something that we can't do and yet we
know this politically those guys could
do a lot of things that we that we can't
do I've got to unfortunately I'm up at a
break here I I hear that episode three
is coming out today it's up now and it's
an outdoor is on the anniversary on
Saturday for is that the anniversary is
actually on Saturday it's the eighth
anniversary where else can people find
you all over the Internet well I'm at
Bill little calm and that's where most
of my stuff is but it's been just such a
pleasure working here with you guys and
and the work that you did to bring this
to life here is just just tremendous yes
it is my pleasure to give this podcast
as much publicity as I can because it is
it is really astounding work Apollo 11
what we saw hosted by the one and only
Bill Whittle bill thanks for coming by
thank you Mike
all right we've got to head over to
Daley wire.com right now we still have a
lot to get to today but coming up
tonight 7:00 p.m. Eastern 4:00 Pacific
tune in to our next episode of daily
wire backstage daily wired god-king
jeremy boring ben shapiro Andrew Klavan
and yours truly will be sipping whiskey
smoking stogies and laughing our way
through politics and pop culture as
always only daily wire subscribers get
to ask the questions so make sure to
subscribe today go to daily wire comm we
will be right back with so much more
all right we've just talked about the
greatest achievement of exploration in
the history of mankind let's talk about
the exact opposite of great achievements
stupid petty political trivialities on
the floor of the House of
Representatives there was genuinely some
craziness yesterday Nancy Pelosi Speaker
of the House took to the floor of the
house and called President Trump a
racist I know this is so brave you've
never you I can't believe Nancy Pelosi
would do that
the reason this mattered I mean
obviously Democrats have called her or
have called Trump racist now for years
and years
the reason this mattered is you're not
allowed to do that you're not allowed to
engage in personality attacks under
parliamentary rules in the House of
Representatives so actually as she was
giving these remarks GOP members moved
to have her comments taken away and she
refused to do it and she was actually
rebuked the Speaker of the House rebuked
in the House of Representatives here she
is every single member of this
institution Democratic and Republican to
join us in condemning the president's
racist tweets to do anything less would
be a shocking rejection of our values
and a shameful abdication of our oath of
office to protect the American people
I urge and note back the balance of my I
was just going to give the general
Speaker of the House if she would like
to rephrase that comment I had cleared
my remarks as a parliamentarian before I
read them
and take it and afterwards be taken down
I'll make a point of wards the
gentlewoman's words are on parliamentary
arrest where he to be taken down the
chair will remind all numbers please
please do not make comments toward
personality-based
personnel debase comments that's a
pretty amazing exchange but it's also
hilarious because if you can't make
personality-based comments then
democrats would have nothing to say they
would fall silent so they make this
remark you can't make personality based
comments and then in the same breath the
House voted to call President Trump a
racist seriously that's what they voted
on doing the people's business this is
what the American people elected them
for they a call Trump a racist and then
they voted to call Trump a racist this
resolution passed along party line votes
240 to 187 there were only four
Republicans who voted to call Trump a
racist and then Justin Amash that
sanctimonious ex Republican libertarian
whatever you want to call them the rest
of the Republicans voted against this
resolution and specifically this was
about President Trump's tweets just a
few days ago where he said that these
Congress women who hate America should
go back to her they came from the issue
being but only one of them is an
immigrant three of them are not
immigrants and this was widely
considered racially offensive I did a
lot of my show on this two days ago so
if you're curious to hear what I thought
about it feel free to go over there I
won't I won't rehash all of it but I
will say the debt the Republicans who
voted against this resolution are
getting a lot of flack for it right now
really just from the mainstream media
and from squishy GOP members and from
the left they were absolutely right to
vote against it this resolution was just
completely stupid and wrong even if you
believe that President Trump's comments
were racially offensive or racist or
bigoted whichever word you want to use
this resolution still was extremely
stupid and the reason for that is it
didn't merely call Trump a racist it
said the president Trump's quote racist
have legitimized fear and hatred of new
Americans and people of color whatever
Trump's tweets did they didn't do that
they didn't legitimize fear and hatred
of new Americans and people of color his
comments were only very precisely
directed toward these very progressive
loudmouth progra freshmen congresswoman
and so it may be at legitimized fear and
disapproval of the squad didn't
legitimize fear and disapproval of a
people of color I mean president Trump
has plenty of people of color working in
his administration he has repeatedly
disavowed racism he's called it evil
he's condemned it repeatedly as far as
anti-semitism goes there's a train
station in a town in Israel named after
him the charge that he is some awful
racial bigotry some neo-nazi or some
white supremacist is just plain stupid
and if his comments legitimized fear and
disapproval of the squad aoc Ilhan Omar
Ayanna Presley and Rasheeda Talib they
we should point out they've legitimized
fear and disapproval of the squad
themselves for instance when L ha no
more giggles about Al Qaeda and refuses
to condemn al Qaeda when members of the
squad work to have lenient punishments
for people who have left America to go
and become Isis terrorists when they
compare America to Nazi Germany and
concentration camps they're the ones
who've legitimized fear of against
themselves when Ilhan Omar laughs about
9/11 and said some people did something
that's why they're the ones doing it
it's not-it's not the fault of president
Trump's tweet so this was the resolution
that was passed on the house obviously
nobody cares they called Trump racist
yesterday they're gonna call Trump
racist today they're gonna call Trump
racist tomorrow did they did the same
thing to George Bush they did the same
thing to George Bush his father they did
the same thing to Ronald Reagan and
guess what they're gonna do the same
thing to the next Republican regardless
of how many times he condemns racial
bigotry but in case people missed it in
case people missed this point that Trump
is an awful racist
CNN decided to have a white supremacist
on Jake Tapper's show guy named Richard
Spencer - also call president Trump
racist and unfortunately for CNN those
guys can't win for losing
the segment didn't go quite as they had
hoped that it would here's CNN
interviewing white nationalist Richard
Spencer white nationalist Richard
Spencer who hailed Trump when he was
first elected is among those who are
turning on Trump many white nationalists
will eat up this red meat that Donald
Trump is throwing out there I am NOT one
of them I recognize the con game that is
going on they say Trump's is all talk
and no action on maintaining white
dominance in America he gives us nothing
outside of racist tweets and by racist
tweets
I mean tweets that are meaningless and
cheap and express the kind of sentiments
you might hear from your drunk uncle
while he's watching Hannity there it is
that guy's is pretty good on camera I
mean this is why it's a bad idea I think
to put him on camera is because he
really has no following he's a very very
fringe figure and the only reason that
anyone knows his name is because the
mainstream media talked about him he's
basically a contrivance of the
mainstream media so he's happy to go on
TV he thinks that if he can go on and
make a joke about sean hannity then he
can attract a few more followers and he
gives them a little bit of what they
want he says that the tweet is racist
but he also says in case you missed it
that President Trump has not governed as
a racist obviously he's not governed as
a racist they don't name towns in Israel
after racists
you know the racists don't create
economic conditions that lead to record
low minority unemployment they don't
hire a lot of racial minorities they
don't talk they don't behave the way
Trump behaves now all Spencer cares
about is race so he's going to only talk
in racial terms but let's forget race
for a second let's go beyond that to
just the broad question of political
rhetoric versus political reality it is
true of virtually every Trump supporter
that I talked to actually even many
Trump critic
they like what he's doing but they don't
always like the way he talks about what
he's doing they don't like when he talks
about Micah's face they don't like the
mean tweets they don't like that he
talks about psychopaths washed-up singer
Bette Midler but they do like what he's
doing so now the whole left is calling
Trump racist what's more interesting
than what they are doing what what is
what is happening is what is not
happening what they're not doing they're
calling Trump racist they're calling
America Nazi Germany they're calling ice
detention facilities concentration camps
like Auschwitz and Dachau but they're
not voting to impeach Trump they're
saying Trump is Hitler this is the 1930s
Donald Trump is the Fuhrer but we're not
going to impeach him they're all talk
why won't they impeach him because they
don't believe it they don't believe what
they're saying they don't think he's
this awful racist bigot they don't think
America's like Nazi Germany and they
don't think that Isis operating
concentration camps at least the elites
tone ANSI Pelosi doesn't think that
maybe some of the rank-and-file do but
all the sideshows in the world don't
matter because Nancy pull up why is
Nancy Pelosi going out here and saying
he's a racist I don't care if I'm
rebuked Dada he's a racist he's our why
is CNN pushing this because then they
don't have to do the actual implication
of what they're saying they don't have
to impeach him but some people are Al
Green the congressman not the singer has
now introduced articles to impeach and
this puts Democrats in a real pickle
because they don't want to vote for it
because they have the numbers and it
would pass so whoever doesn't vote for
it he's going to incite the fury of the
base the radical Democratic base the
donors the people who hand out palm
cards they don't they want impeachment
the American people don't want
impeachment they the American people
feel that since the 2016 election
Hillary basically never conceded she
said it was rigged she said it was
stolen the Democrats have said this it
was the Russians it was the Macedonians
it was James Comey it was everybody but
us
now there's another presidential
election but and they're still trying to
take it away from him all these
investigations all this impeachment all
these non traverses but
impeachment comes up not voting for it
expresses the leftist hypocrites and to
top it all off the feud with the squad
is back on so we were told the president
Trump's tweets had stopped all the
Democrat infighting between a OSI and
Nancy Pelosi turns out that's not true
tune in to CBS and you find out the feud
is back on are you speaking to Nancy
Pelosi our teams are in communication
are cheap sorry but shouldn't it be a
face to face I want to know if you were
see the new member not the speaker
nobody has every right to sit down with
her in any moment anytime with any of us
she is Speaker of the House she can ask
for a meeting to sit down with us for
clarification the fact of the knowledge
is and I've done racial justice work in
our country for a long time
acknowledge the fact that we are women
of color so when you do singles out be
aware of that and what you're doing
especially because some of us are
getting death threats because some of us
are being singled out in many ways
because of our backgrounds because of
our experiences and so forth
but I think are you interested in having
a conversation face-to-face with Speaker
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi when she sit
down with her yeah no absolutely and
we've reached out to that end so the
feud is back on except now the only
difference between today and a few days
ago is now the bulk of Democrats are
rallying behind those women they're
rallying behind the squad they're not
they're not exactly backing Pelosi I
mean Pelosi was rebuked on the floor of
the House of Representatives for
goodness sakes she's the Speaker of the
House this raises the question were the
tweets politically astute were they the
right thing to send for president Trump
it wasn't a home run he actually screwed
up he shouldn't have told the people who
were born here to go back to their own
countries he should have phrased it
differently and said go check out those
foreign countries get out of here I
think he could have gotten all the
political running out of it without
putting him in that bind where he said
something that was just factually untrue
so it wasn't a home run but it was a
base hit and it really maybe it was a
double if you look at where the left is
now you now have the left and this
political bind they're introducing
articles of impeachment or at least
they're trying to you've got them in the
bind where the feud is still going on it
the tweets didn't stop the feud except
now there's a lot more support for these
women who whose support was in the
single digits just a few days ago now
the Democrats are rallying behind them
you've you've got
what what Trump manages to do through
his troll ashiness basically is get the
left to follow their own ideas to their
logical conclusions Planned Parenthood
has never been more radical gender
ideology has never been more radical
these women elected in Congress the four
horsewomen of the political apocalypse
have never been more radical on the
basis going behind them at the end of
this whole tweet episode which is now
going on for like three days it's hard
to imagine how this works at any better
for conservatives it's a good place to
be it's you've got a you got to take the
hits when you can get them we will
examine tomorrow how this all looks for
2020 get your mailbag questions and
we'll get to them then in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show I'll see you backstage
tonight and on the show tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua Alvaro and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show Democrats pass a
resolution condemning Trump's
quote/unquote racist tweets and we
explain the poll numbers that's today on
the bench Shapiro show